that is London  sixty minutes is all it took to bring  humanity to the very brink of extinction  mankind mobilized a new age arose age  the great predator city's survival of  the fastest  hey watch out Valentina this is for my  mother  stop  ask him what you murdered my mother  I'm sorry you had to Heather  [Music]  as to Shawn she won't stop until I'm  dead unless you kill her first I want  them found  I've been looking for you for a long  time your mother she said she had found  something dangerous  she was afraid of Valentine of what he  might do man who controls this controls  the world she said that you could stop  him  this weapon can wipe out the largest  city in the blink of an eye  not if we shut it down  nothing can stand in the face of this we  have to stop London before it destroys  us  you sure you want to do this once we go  in there's no going back I have to  you  you